more than 100 billion dollars remained
stuck in lebanon's banks since 2019 when
the financial system collapsed
depositors have been facing limits on
withdrawals at unfavorable exchange
rates
now some banks are closing accounts of
mainly british passport holders after a
uk court ordered a lebanese bank to give
a depositor his money depositors say
they are offered a check for the balance
but they are worth less than 20 percent
of their value
manager of the bank told me that i can
take my check
at the notaries
and wander
around
and see who can accept
a
banker's check
banks say they are short of cash and
fear if depositors continue winning
legal challenges they will have to
declare bankruptcy they say the answer
is for the political authorities to pass
a law that would regulate the outflow of
foreign currency
capital control measures
that would have
even the level playing field for all
depositors it would have prevented all
these accusations against banks of
favoring certain depositors over others
favoring politicians over regular
citizens
banks have been accused of helping the
politically connected transfer their
money abroad many of them are
shareholders in lebanon's largest banks
critics called the financial system a
ponzi scheme for decades banks lent to
the state at high interest rates while
successive governments largely plundered
funds and piled up debt until capital
inflows slowed and the economy collapsed
and experts believe much of the money is
now gone with people locked out of their
savings as they struggle with high
inflation and poverty
so there are many challenges in order to
get the money back we cannot just get it
back by doing individual
lawsuits and also we have to see a
restructuring of the banking sector and
the public debt and this is what's not
happening
those in power have so far failed to
reform a system that they long benefited
from
it's been to shift the losses to the
people who withdraw their money at
around 30 percent of its value already
depositors have lost billions of dollars
senator al-jazeera beirut